I I thought that we knew everything
already until I started doing research
and for me to come in and be like I have
to lay the foundations of knowledge it's
weird it feels like I'm bending the laws
of nature it's like it's hard to know
where to go or where to look
so like sometimes it's just you know
whatever you want to see take yourself
there take that risks and if it doesn't
take you anywhere then you'll have your
answer but more times than not you'll
realize that it opens and it doesn't end
like you might explore something
impossible and start to see that it's
actually leading you to something you
might be afraid that it leads you astray
but even then what's the point of life
if you're not even enjoying being astray
because that's probably what our whole
line is I'm I feel like it's about it's
like enjoying that chase - boom what's
up everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sake on we are still in
Cambridge in Massachusetts we are now
going to be talking about brain
technologies we have Alexei showing us
on the show hello everyone thank you so
much here hang on I'm really grateful
for Sara new Schwab Canova for
introducing us thank you we love you we
love you serious shout out to you and
this is gonna be a lot of fun Alexis
background check this out he's a neuro
engineer paving the way for interfacing
our minds with machines he's a PhD
student at MIT working on developing new
technologies to help us understand and
repair the brain and you can check out
Alexie's LinkedIn link below
all right Alexi let's start things off
with the one of our favorite questions
we like asking we find ourselves as
stewards of Earth what is your current
take on the state of humanity state of
humanity I think we can go both ways
things are going good things are going
bad things are going I think I'd like to
be optimistic I think each moment I feel
like the the human spirit
we when things go down when we hit rock
bottom we'll find a way to pick
ourselves up it's cyclical goes up and
down but overall trajectories going up
and I think you know times right now
seems like they might be plateauing
there's there's tension but I I trust
we'll pull ourselves out I think we
always do so that's kind of my take on
that yeah yeah I hope that this time
that we are approaching this very
prominent / pinnacle moment of
technological advancement and
development that we make it through and
not go back yeah
no more cycle it was like just up to the
acceleration I feel that yeah I feel
that for sure we have plotted a lot that
we're dealing with yeah let's jump into
the journey okay how did you become who
you are today because born in Lebanon
and then came to the US and then back to
Lebanon so I was initially born in the
US but my parents wanted me to grow up
and Lebanon so I had my first birthday
there with my twin brother and pretty
much grew up there and then came back to
the US for for high school in college
and now I'm still here
border back to Lebanon for 12 years 12
years well yes what you said a brother
you have twin brother yeah I have a
couple of other siblings too I like you
know even though yes I do it looks
nothing like me
oh he dobbert probably yeah Bobby yeah
cuz how would I know you could
potentially be by ok so he has red hair
in the articles so his red hair decals
it's so weird how that happened yeah
yeah adoption but yeah so my parents
want him to go back things were settled
there they had left because of issues
there initially but you know they wanted
me to figure out my roots culture pick
that up being there was amazing very
diverse beautiful country there's
political turmoil turmoil from time to
time got exposure to poverty war
different religions we did ultimately
leave in 2006 because of a war that
broke out so I was a US citizen living
abroad in Lebanon being Lebanese and
yeah we were evacuated by the by the
American military so I had I had to
leave couldn't say bye to my friends or
family it was a quick decision my mom
woke me up out of bed and we had to go
then we it was like that you literally
my mom woke me up said grab a backpack
we're leaving I didn't know I was coming
to the u.s. I was still in the 6th grade
I had loved the US I came once for a
wedding but beyond that it happened all
of the sudden that's how that's how wars
work so Wow yeah you know things happen
for a reason they inspired me showed me
that the true nature of the world or at
least they how humans can do things that
you know I kind of view things as I
never feel bad I never feel I kind of
feel like these are all things I look at
and it inspires me what I want the
future to look like so it's not really
something that I I don't embody the fear
that I experience in general I you know
it was an adventure that's how I view it
and all it does is push me it doesn't
stop me so so yeah I think the scary
part was really coming to the u.s. it
was it was a culture shock I didn't
really we moved to Arizona the desert
and I'm just trying to come and make new
friends all the sudden get used to the
culture I think that was one of the
biggest elements but um but yeah that
growing up in the Middle East
I felt like science was my rock I felt
like there are different religions
people are fighting for I found I felt
drawn to nature I used to love watching
nature videos I felt like science had
answers there there was numbers there
was no argument so to me at that at that
point in my life I really felt like
science gave me a sense of stability
about maybe we can find ways to explain
what's going on around us and that way
we can develop ways to intervene so from
from my mind I felt by understanding
what's happening around us we can
engineer solutions and I fundamentally
was interested in humans in the human
condition and that led me to being
interested in the mind in the brain and
how we behaved why you behave you know
and I initially wanted to be a doctor to
help people but then as I saw that
things go beyond the body like I also
studied economics in college I got very
interested in poverty I got very
interested in many many other things so
like holistically how can we how can we
intervene because science is one element
that I start to realize over time but
yeah this is the story of of you seeing
the human behavior around you and
wanting to understand how humans work in
order to be able to tackle and to
intervene in creating potentially more
peace and harmony I think that's very
beautiful when you position science as
this rock that's an objective rock and
in a very subjective battle
yeah thoughts and all this other type of
yeah and you know I I think it I
rationalize and I think initially it was
I was emotionally drawn to it it's just
you're curious about the nature of
reality also my interaction with my
cousin who had brain cancer when he was
8 he's much older now things like that
began you begin to question like why is
there disease can I do anything about it
what is cancer you know my my family
didn't really know how to dive deeper
they just knew what it was so it was
like kind of my curiosity with there are
problems here
you know just at a very young age and no
one had the answers I would ask the
dumbest questions all the time why are
bananas yellow why is the sky blue and
like my parents just had to deal with
that you know it's just there was
something about where I was I was not
satisfied with the answers I was getting
which drove me deeper and deeper into
trying to figure things out not only
because I'm inherently curious I think
that's the one one element but huge yeah
probably the most important driving
force and then you know the applications
of that yeah yeah you you would take the
curiosity that you have about you know
really why does cancer happen or why are
bananas yellow a yeah you would apply
that understanding into learning about
how things actually work in the world
it's like a translational curiosity one
that gives you an expanded awareness you
have the story of of being you know
having war or or any type of violent
uprising cause a an evacuation there's a
nuts thing to happen but it's also very
interesting how you phrase it as
something that potentially has been that
this great challenge that you've now
found the greatest treasures on the
other side oh yeah yeah I'm you know at
this point in my life I try and
transcend like the duality of good or
bad and I think things are caught
there's contrast and it steers us
because I I can be a very pessimistic if
I want to and it could hold me back you
know and sometimes all we have is what's
in front of us and you know in a way I
when you when you feel like your victim
long enough and you exhaust yourself you
can't help but feel like there has to be
something I can do and I can't just sit
here and you know you know I I always
feel like yeah the thing the things that
happened to me it propelled me and I am
grateful for them and they in a way
not that I'm masochistic or anything is
just totally just yeah grateful for the
challenges for us to have the goal of
overcoming them and learning you you
know this is you know it's making more
sense about how you shaped your your
interest in in neuroscience and human
behavior
now I want to want to get a little bit
deeper into you know at the same time as
you're really making the move here and
you're like 12 when you're making the
move here and you're in Arizona but then
you end up pursuing your PhD at MIT Yeah
right throughout this process you also
have a through your insatiable curiosity
you're realizing you know how crazy
interesting it is that we have this
consciousness that it gives us the
ability to perceive and educate
ourselves and to feel and also create
and so I loved how you were teaching
about that yeah I I think in a way I was
I was in high school and I was like what
am I going to do and I I just felt like
somehow the mind was this singular point
the black box that encompassed us you
know we had to fundamentally understand
biology to understand the brain that can
really help us just understand how cells
work but then there's mind and behavior
which might help us with dealing with
with poverty with mental health with
with violence things at the political
level law on even try and derive
computations for artificial intelligence
I just felt like if I could be in this
space that I could just maximize my
effect on many many things and
fundamentally understand myself which I
think we're all doing every day and
understand others and try and bridge
that gap and make things more relatable
I think sometimes that the brain taught
me how to forgive people if you know I
remember earlier in my life it's like if
someone was angry you know I would just
be like this is a response this is this
is all they know it I it was an object
that allowed it almost allowed me to
blame their brain and not them you know
you can you can find many ways to to to
develop empathy you know studying
sociopaths or you know things of that
form it just made me feel like there's
there's a tangibility to to the problems
in the world if we can understand the
rain so yeah so that led me so III did a
lot of research in college I was
interested in just understanding how
neurons work and how they how genetics
might relate to neurological disorders
but then I start to realize that when I
got to grad school at MIT that I got
less interested in discovering things
because I felt we were limited by our
technologies and I just think it's in
the air at MIT so I picked up
engineering neural engineering
specifically as a field to develop
technologies that can make us and we
used the word interrogate the brain
study the brain in ways we couldn't
before and you know there's a funny
analogy where neuroscience right now is
we're trying to paint the car to get to
the moon so meaning like we need we need
more tools we need to build rockets you
need to build telescopes like we are
there are using paintbrushes instead of
yeah making the new tools the adze
rockets telescopes all right I felt that
when I was trying to decide what to do
with my PhD I felt in a way very
hopeless that the conclusions that we
make about the brain that because it's
so complex billions of neurons and
trillions connections millions of
molecules in each neuron I just felt
like there is no way in my lifetime that
I'm going to help so I I felt like it in
order to catalyze this I needed to enter
the enter the technology space to help
empower us to build the tools to help us
see further to expand the visibility get
more numbers more data whatever it takes
to understand the system so that was the
mindset I took to enter the neuro
technology space was - it gives us the
ability to understand the brain and by
understanding its intricacies we can
think of intricate solutions so really
it's kind of like this feedback of
understanding what the problem is which
we fundamentally do not know what causes
disease
in the brain we don't even know how a
single neuron works and there are people
that study worms that have only three
hundred neurons compared to like a
hundred billion we don't even know how
it makes decisions so just to say like
there's work that needs to be done but
there are efforts in this space and
attempt to again tie into all the things
I said that would maximize impact like
the brain in some ways is the last
frontier
at least we think right now yeah well we
think right now yeah that's because then
we hit a wall you know hopefully new
frontiers continuously open up
I like how you explained that taking an
engineering lens enables us to have more
tools of building the the telescopes and
the and the rockets to actually get to
the moon with the brain that's a really
good way to put it also the tools open
up more creative solutions for other
people to study the brain as well as
build more tools themselves they gain
inspiration from that so that's a great
way of putting neural engineering
specifically and in a way to wrap that
up what developing to research tools
specifically it allows you to answer
questions you couldn't answer before so
you can have as many questions as you
want but if you don't have ways of
exploring them they're just going to be
questions so really it it enables us to
explore the questions we've always
wanted to so you know in a way it's yeah
it's it's very important to help us
understand things and to me
fundamentally there's no point
intervening until we understand and a
lot of time we're looking for magic
bullets and things of that form and
they're they're riskier as things get
more and more complicated we're working
with higher dimensions higher
dimensional datasets the brain just too
complex to just find one thing so we
need to to really understand its
complexity and that requires more
complex tools billions of neurons
trillions of connections and millions of
molecules in every neuron yeah that's
crazy
as thousands millions yeah I don't know
how many molecules your age but yeah but
that's just yeah that's crazy that
there's a lot going yeah there's so much
going on and then to be able to make the
tools that make it better for us to do
understand ourselves understand others
understand human behavior and then also
understand how to cure the diseases that
plague so many of us dementia etc to
teach us about your fascination with
making the tools that is gonna help with
curing disease and what because you're
telling me earlier you're like what are
we going to put a wire on every neuron
so what are you thinking is is the way
that we tackle this so so I think
sometimes there are kind of limits to
our imagination and I feel like right
now this is the best we can do given
what's available to us because sometimes
when I look further out it feels like
there's something better always and I
think it's about building what we can
now seeing its flaws and making them
obsolete and moving forward so in some
ways a lot of the technology is being
developed in the space are not ready for
humans we have bigger brains we have
more neurons that will require scaling
of some form and finding ways that are
less invasive if we decide that we want
to start directly connecting things with
with the skull I think elements that I
think you know physicists might find
ways of really developing new forms of
let's say penetrating the skull and
stimulating or inhibiting neurons think
about you know think about the first
part is understanding the brain is
understanding the notes to a piano to a
song and then that we need to develop
the fingers to go back in and play them
so if you have a diseased brain and a
healthy
we want to know the difference in how
the brain is computing and then
understanding is literally one part the
next part is reintroducing those
computations artificially to bring us
back to a normal state of how the brain
should be operating the reintroduction
of what the degeneration has caused in a
computational way yeah with like with an
excitatory yes and so we're which we're
trying to figure out what the fingers
how to make these fingers to play those
notes again yeah so if you if you have
Alzheimer's and you forgot your memories
we technically need to know what memory
is where they store it how are they
stored so we know how to intervene and
re-upload your memories hypothetically
so it's it's really this interplay of
right now we are in the phase of we need
to understand what's happening at least
that's my opinion and then that will
lead to a sense of where can we
intervene and then we would develop
intervention methods for that okay so
but that's much lot more long-term I
really liked how you discuss the
importance of understanding how the
brain works as this most important
principle because otherwise it almost
seems as though everything else that
we're doing is a little bit not educated
enough of a guess of an understanding
pre tackling neuro degeneration or pre
tackling stimulation etc I mean there
are no cures for neurological disorders
disorders zero clinical trials are being
shut down pharma companies are spending
billions of dollars nothing is working
because that we're trying to find simple
solutions for complex problems which i
think is important but you know it's
coming from a place to where we're
studying let's say animals and we're
trying to bring it to humans and our
brains are different mean we're much
we're just different then
than a mouse which is where you know
what scientists study because that's
what's available and then what things
move up to to humans things start to
break down when it comes to the brain
we've been able to you know develop ways
of treating infection and cancer but
neurological disorder we're finding of a
hard time and mainly because we don't
understand the brain and try to
understand it is very complex as I just
kind of give you a sense of that and you
know this is all under the assumption
that we're again I sometimes I like to
play devil's advocate where the brain is
also inside of a body I mean there is
the rest of the body like we are part of
a system so degeneration can let's you
know the disease could be caused by
something else my behavior could be
caused by the adrenaline being pumped
from another part of my body so like I
think but you know science is attempting
to just find all the pieces and we will
integrate it together at some point but
right now the the brain is so unknown
that we just need to chip away at it and
see what comes from it I think something
that you and I were talking about right
before the interview was that there are
non technological interventions that can
augment the our health to such a degree
where potentially we don't even die from
the onset of cancer we don't die from
the onset of Alzheimer's but maybe
something else but so how do we do that
in a non technological yeah so I think
sometimes science is an attempt at
generalization so the ability to study
something and apply to mass population
and and then you know in a way each
human is just special I mean our genetic
makeups our lives you know where we are
our epigenome you know no one may ever
live the same life I had I eat the same
food I've had gone that so like what is
inside my body is so complex so
sometimes you know science science is
attempting to do that but at the same
time we also need
find ways to take preventative measures
you know I mean some some people might
have bad habits it in a way like I don't
want to end go here but there are
financial structures that lead us
sometimes with the momentum of
developing you know sometimes there's a
momentum financial incentive to do
science and and and develop medications
and I think it should happen but I also
think that if our if we want to solve
the problem you know there's also ways
that we can minimize health risks
whatever that whatever that is really
thinking outside the box
right now it's we're stuck with the
model of ah ah the pharmaceuticals are
the trials are but really the way that
we behave in a day to day basis if we're
more meditative we're less stressful if
you eat better and exercise more and
don't smoke yeah we can live longer
yeah and prevent the onset of some of
these yet physiological issues yeah and
yeah so that's that's why I think in
addition to science people should really
try become more in tune with themselves
I mean once you go to an N of one which
is one person I mean there's no more
statistics so whatever it takes to make
you feel good it can be subjective you
can be experimental with yourself and I
mean that just like figure out what
works for you what makes you feel good
what can you eat that makes you feel
good what you know and how much does
your mind play a role over your body so
like these are things that that should
be be done in parallel and complementary
I you know I think science has done
amazing things and it will continue to
but I think it's important that we also
you know there's something that like I
just mentioned the scale of the brain
when you reduce each individual to all
these molecules and all these neurons it
just gets really hard to figure out like
what's happening for each and like for
me to understand who you are I would
need to technically have
brain analyze your brain and your
environment yeah like what are you
eating every day who you thought like
there's your brain takes and inputs it
takes in stimuli so like it is not
separate from your environment so for me
to really understand you I would have to
follow you your whole life and met you'd
have to have wearables I would have to
take your blood you know it's just it
gets a little ridiculous I know we're
moving towards a data-driven world but
you know how much resolution do we need
how big of a data set do we need and you
know you it's like you need to know
everything that's happening around you
so it becomes like you have to almost
like how are you gonna do that for each
person for over over their lifetime so
like to 100% understand another person
you would need every single one of their
sensory inputs they've had throughout
their entire life and even prior to that
yeah yeah so this is where things break
down for me sometimes when I look far
into the future I think it's okay to
explore the unknown because it hasn't
been done and I think you know this is
how we we push the limits of humanity's
just doing what we know is within the
bounds of our imagination right now
hitting that wall breaking through it
and thinking of something better but
right now you know I could see the walls
with their reductionist mentality which
is what science is attempting it's done
a really good job in helping us build
things and get to the moon but as we get
to biological systems it's noisy it's
very pro there's a lot of statistics a
lot of chance a lot of noise it's just
it gets scary engine engineers are in
physicists and mathematicians are
entering this space because it's it's a
challenge and they're looking for a
challenge yeah and the biggest we're
scared yeah we're scared and excited at
least I am to get a handle on this and I
think we need to be open-minded and
humble to what the limits are because I
think sometimes we come in with this is
I came in you know I'm halfway through
my ph.d program really feeling like this
is going to solve everything
and I still think it should be pursued
but I also think we should
be looking for four other ways like we
had touched on the individual and you
know again science is assuming that math
and physics are real I mean that's the
foundation of it we invented numbers you
know one into the idea that we can
separate things that things are causal
and interact but like how I just said
the environment and the brain are
intertwined so really is there me and
the environment or is there is it all
like long one yeah so that that's when
it gets weird like what what do I do I'm
creating this separate artificial
separation to study it and then to
intervene artificially and it works but
sometimes it gets it starts to break
down a bit and it's it's a it's it's not
easy to talk about this because this is
what our well I like built on I like
this this approach of it's it's um it's
a very curious it's a philosophical it's
a so it's an approach that does not
separate the brain from the environment
to such a degree that they are so
coupled in this this realm of oneness
that we could we could go as far as to
say that the the cities that we live in
are potentially causing a certain
percentage of the neuro degeneration
that we experience distress that we take
on from the nine to five grind that were
on yeah the even this couch here is this
a really the most optimal way for our
bodies to be sitting yet while we're
having a conversation
ya know yeah there's a much more optimal
way for our bodies to be positioned yeah
so in a way like it I you see where I'm
coming from and we're you know people
people in the public health space are
trying to understand things at like a
more global perspective macroscale like
our behaviors what do we buy where are
we going but yeah end of the day in a
weird way all we have of is ourselves
and the only thing monitoring ourselves
each moment is our intuition and we can
try and help use wearables and tools to
bring those things to our awareness to
help us make sense of what we want to do
what choices we want to make because
that you know you are your own authority
but you know we we're trying to make
sense of it and it's important and yes
we should explore the things so one
besides disease again but this also will
tie to the solution is imagine that
we're all perfectly healthy and I'm
going to take this space and there's
something more than that
I think I still think we there might be
problems if all disease is cured I think
there's something about finding our role
where we are in each moment that causes
problems to our relationships with
ourselves
yeah meaning finding meaning yeah and I
think things eventually also that's
something we need to address I think we
get lost in the rationale I think for a
while like I I was driven by science
because of out of curiosity then when
you start really thinking about things
like this meaning things break down and
it becomes subjective to everyone and
when you try to really create an
objective reality for everyone it starts
putting people in a box and I think it
kind of even if you're perfectly healthy
might not feel like you want to fit in
that in that system of how things should
work so yeah I like I do feel like it's
hard to tell exactly that could cause
stress that could suppress your immune
system that might lead to riskier
behaviors and all these other diseases
like it could tie into just like this
existential I can literally sit here and
do stress in my body if I wanted to like
you know what I mean I could sit here
and worry if I really kind of a thing
'king about my place in in realities so
like I I do I do think what people think
of themselves and their relation to go
there it's just suit yourself faster if
you're doing with your mind yeah in an
interesting way yeah so we need to be
conscious of how we make ourselves feel
you know it's very easy to fall into a
rut and not feel good about yourself I
mean it's just part of human nature and
sometimes we need to catch ourselves and
know that it doesn't benefit us in any
way to do that you'll start feeling it
in your body I mean that's a sign that
you should
try and think better thoughts but then
it's like ah we might feel that
negativity is we need to think because
you might find yourself in a negative
loop because you're thinking and you
want to find the solution but sometimes
it's just again like I had said about my
life being hopeful that just that
attitude shift might be enough for you
to see things differently and actually
be healthier and feel like you can make
the right choices so it gets hard you
know it gets hard it's like if you do
science from a place of fear versus you
know passion and love and hope you know
you're gonna build two different things
you're gonna build cures or weapons so
like it does come down to fundamentally
like how we feel about ourselves and it
will come down to that I think for a lot
of things too so yeah things around us
are tools and it comes down to how we
feel about ourselves how we using great
power comes great responsibility type
stuff actually I think this is probably
the first time that I'm really realizing
how much we don't think about the
environment that we've built around the
yeah bodies yeah yeah and what that this
the cyclical feedback that we had
between the body and the environment on
a moment-to-moment basis and I love
thinking about it that way and also I
want to say this you know you've also
helped me realize that we're we have
we're using child's play with brain
technology right now we're Ichi and fMRI
and even trying to put electrodes into
even into our brain to try and
understand the complexity of it it's
child's play and so eventually we'll get
to a new frontier in a row technology
yeah we're gonna make new tools and
neuro engineering it's gonna be
fantastic
agreed and it's gonna do great work but
in the meanwhile here I think thinking
outside of the
in terms of what our invite what's going
on in our environment and all that kind
of stuff it's a great way to do it in a
you use use this word a non
technological intervention in to help
yeah yeah so in a way I mean words are
words you know they're anything can be a
technology even a toothpick so like in a
way it's just maybe thinking about
because when I studied economics I think
about systemic behaviors how do we
operate collectively and you know
instead of yes not taking this reduction
in approach if there are studies showing
that if if a mouse is addicted to
cocaine if you put them in an
environment with toys that they they
they stop taking the cocaine their
addictions go away you can think about
our world and our habits just come down
to there we're just not happy where we
are and I feel that sometimes that if
we're in a place where so one thing is
like loving yourself but also feeling
that people support you community is
super important culture music and
humanities things that lift us up in
ways that science can't measure it's
just you can just enter another state
and your outlook and your health is
benefited by that it's very systemic
it's very holistic yeah and you know to
segue I have thought of ways like
instead of trying to really pick at each
cell and molecule in the body what if we
built in new city had another
Renaissance got rid of things we don't
want to do anymore let's say with robots
if we can fully automate the things that
we don't want to do anymore give people
meaning in their lives by giving them
the freedom to do what they want when
they want and express it without being
bound maybe by things that they need to
do yes you know and we should like we
need to thrive and like I said like it
goes beyond if we are all healthy it
just comes out to what do we do what are
they we have one life at least we're
told and
it's possible that we could develop ways
and lifestyles to live forever let's say
we do live forever what are we gonna do
each day you know are we gonna work
every day are we gonna just do things
for other people or we're gonna do
things for ourselves so it comes down to
again this human centric idea of like
how do we change with our society do we
start from scratch do I just you know go
to the desert get get there at the group
of people and just like start a new
society you know I do think about these
things how can I be myself how what if
you know I think about the the concept
of language like what if I was born into
a world and no one taught me math or
English or what the other languages I
know yeah how would I make sense of my
environment yeah would it benefit me
more to just come up with the
explanations myself without trying to
fit in fit in words and numbers it's
radical it requires you to think about a
lot yeah I even go as far as to think of
not not teaching language to get a child
and keeping them in an environment I
know that some radical stuff because but
you can get the police I'm sure in a way
you use structure
it brings us to our feet but then it's
also important that we break away
because what yeah we've to explore
creative yeah yeah the construct we live
in within language because words are
very loaded yeah sometimes it's about
breaking away from that and look at
finding new ways how do you find new
ways to think you know I yes it's yeah
it's hard and that it somehow comes from
you and if you're original and you're
you're coming up with an idea that no
one has came up with before you feel out
of place you feel like you're crazy you
feel like it's wrong because you need
everyone else to agree but it has to
come from a place of originality first
so how do you trust that you know how do
you trust yourself and that's what I
mean where it's about this freedom of
having an environment where you can
bring out new ideals and not feel judged
or even judge yourself and I think
that's a recipe for innovation and
creativity and longevity things of that
form yeah is our yeah we spend so much
money on
health and that's preventive and so it's
interesting thinking about if the basic
physiological needs are met and then the
creative flourishing is able to happen
for every human how much money would we
actually be spending on health care at
that point and then also on the on the
time side of things I don't know if
would how fast would we move towards our
self-actualization and self
transcendence if we weren't bounded by
80 years of time so the ideas I've toyed
around with which seem very difficult to
implement was if there were a city what
would happen if we didn't have time or
age so I don't have to sit here and feel
bad about how old I am and then I'm
getting older or that I have a meeting
like is there a new way of operating
outside of what we are interested in
efficiency and productivity and
optimizing what are we optimizing
towards like people it's literally a
Productivity for the economy it's a
momentum that is taking place that is
not even considering the individuals
themselves and we're losing ourselves in
that yeah and not paying attention to
you know it's a good way to put it yeah
so in a in a way like we want the
numbers for the structure can you have a
city that operates without numbers and
money I think things like cryptocurrency
are attempting to decentralize finance
and empower people and things of that
form so yeah I think we need to question
what our aims are what are the aims of
institutions and it really comes out to
each individual in that institution are
you trying to make money and be
productive or you're trying to feel good
because if you're ignoring that then
you're just creating a beast that you
don't care about and everyone's creating
it together and they don't want to be
there so it's like we have to be careful
and a and again it comes down to
response being its responsible as an
individual but not everyone it's hard to
leave the momentum I mean we're all part
of something so that's why sometimes it
takes someone brave enough to break away
and then bring the group of people
together I mean it's just it's just
that's how it works
I agree there's eight billion of us that
are frayed yeah
the eight billion of us are in the rat
race and it's a we're moving in the
direction of economics and GDP and it's
not about in many ways it's not
prioritizing human flourishing human
creativity like you said what would a
city look like these are very
fundamental questions that we need
children and adolescents and even adults
exploring on a more frequent basis what
would it look like to have be born where
you're not picking up numbers and
language right away but that you're
building up a different way of modeling
the world what would it look like if
there was no time or money or don't feel
bad about your age all these types of
things how would a city like that work
where the human is prioritized their
health their happiness their meaning all
those things are prioritized I love
these thought extends and it does feel
like it we would not have as much of the
stress on our bodies that causes our
deterioration as quickly yeah and you
know it it comes down to I like to say
that words are spells I mean you you
could you could label something and you
you have literally created it with that
label so we need to pay attention to
when we look at an object or an
experience we are in a way defining it
but we were also given that definition
so how can we do in a way that is
realistic and still maintain structures
and allows us to you know move towards
something that where the words you use
are just better all the time you know
like like for example in the English
language people say I might say I am
angry other languages people say I have
anger so just that change really affects
the relationship I have with the word
like I have told of it means it's
temporary and yes so like it's just it's
not me it's just passing
so like in a way you know I can't fly
right now
but technically I would like to say I
can't fly just yet
yeah so again like it's just about how
far can you remove the limits of what's
possible yeah I I would I like to think
that anything is possible I can't prove
that right now but if you could trust
that then you can do things that we
couldn't do before and if you just
simply look at history and where we are
we've already proved that we could do
anything but we forget somehow and it
you know it's it's kind of scary to to
take a leap of faith and feel like you
can do something no one's done but
that's why it's important to just
fundamentally be driven by that
curiosity because you have to take that
chance and sometimes for me for me to
take that chance I just tell myself
anything's possible because I don't want
to do it if it's not gonna work I'm not
interested in failing you know yeah but
like I'll fail when it comes down to it
if it comes down to it but so far it's
all that's done has guided me so again
reusing these words and what did we want
yeah that was really well said is that I
have anger or what it you know we're not
flying yet you know these you yeah words
are spells words are creation thought is
creation so that's a really important
point and also just relating back to the
rat-race
hierarchical a billion of us in the
machine it does make sense think about
when we look at something like a Satoshi
Nakamoto whatever it that is that it was
literally a disconnect making something
completely new integrating that back in
yeah so it's like get out of the 8
billion
rat race hierarchy plug out make
something that obsoletes yeah the old
way of thinking in the hierarchy and
then make it so attractive that it
becomes the mental map that gets
uploaded to all people's code yeah
yeah and so what would that you know
happy so I like the I think store
storytelling is
as a very powerful tool and in a way for
all I know our our lives our collective
stories that we put our eggs in that
basket and we believe in it and it feels
very real when you're born into it and
if you start to feel like there has to
be a better story out there but it's not
real sometimes a question why does my
brain even allow me to have thought
thoughts that aren't real
why can I imagine myself riding a dragon
over the sunset like yeah that sounds
like a waste of time evolutionarily but
I think we allow ourselves to stretch
that limit just to bring us into
possibility and to move us ability space
yeah and the the more convinced you are
of your thoughts and you get enough
people to want that and get together and
things feel like there is a possibility
then you make it a possibility
collectively so I think there is yeah
this is this is nice
there's almost there's almost a a um the
the burden of genius that people take on
is not only related to the amount of of
time and relentless work that they put
on being the first ones to make an
advancement for the rest of civilization
we can ride the dragon over the sunset
we can we can ride there's there's a
certain like with this burden of genius
there is a certain amount of creativity
outside the original code that you have
to realize and then you're imagining it
the flying the dragon or the sunsets
maybe a little bit further out yeah then
maybe making a new neuro engineering
tool yeah right and so then it's up to
you then to be able to put together the
ability to do so this again this brings
us again back to the rat in the cage if
we're all trapped in the economic
hierarchy of of civilization think about
the amount of play structures that we
have how well is this you can literally
tell the difference of rat in a cage
without any two toys and the rat in a
cage with toys has significant further
development and infrastructure that's
built out so why not then be able to
build a city build a built environment
that radically enables are the most
flourished neural infrastructure and
creativity possible it seems as though
us rats as humans in this hierarchy are
not as able to be maximally flourished
as possible so what I'll say is that it
comes down it's a confidence game I
think we don't realize how much power we
have you know in a way we're slaves of
our mind and you know we we're stuck in
a pattern because that's that's how
things are I'm just I'm used to being in
my body and walking I've never tried to
fly I don't think I can fly but for me
to go from 0 to 1 to make something I
have to in a way pick a side and like
for me to say anything is possible I
have to pick that or else if I don't say
that then every choice I make is a
logistical one I can only do things
within the realm of what is possible but
that's boring because it leaves me to
like everything's already here what do I
do I just sit on my couch and watch TV
like how do I go from consumer to
creator how do I make something that
doesn't exist so it requires you to just
again just for me it's just I'm it's
very recent that I'm just trying to
adopt this attitude and it comes from a
place of just feeling like there's
nowhere else to go except bringing
what's in your mind out there and to
trust us somehow your imaginations can
happen and when you just put yourself
out there you'll be surprised that
everyone a lot of people might have the
same thoughts of you then you build a
team and you get together and you share
your vision and you share a dream and I
think for a very long time I I didn't
allow myself to dream I just kind of
felt like everything is the way it is
and I need to work within those bounds
and I told I started really enjoying
thinking about the way things are I
become impatient where I'm at
I need to I need to do what doesn't
exist just to test that I can do
anything so it's just simply getting
caught in that process of proving the
power that we have to ourselves I think
as our ultimate goal is just unraveling
the human potential and seeing that we
can do that and I think that's where
bliss comes from and motivation in
anything that drives us and that's why
that's why I think what we consider
challenges our problems are important I
think I think they help us in a way like
love ourselves more by over overcoming
these these these obstacles that in a
way we placed ourselves but we were
unaware of them and that's fine we just
need to realize that there's something
we can do about it you know it's hard
you know in a way I will do many things
that I feel are so real and it's hard to
question them but it just comes down to
like in a way being fed up the built
environment that we made for the pursuit
of meaning and purpose and
self-actualization of fulfillment the
basic physiological needs to be met is
just not to the degree that it could be
in order to make it easier for people to
pursue exactly what you're talking about
because when you wake up in the morning
you're much less likely to want to
radically change the code of
civilization than you are currently to
get your physiological needs met and
keep playing in the game that is in and
we need more role models to step outside
of the game right the new codes bring
them back into the game or even just
draw new people out of the game into a
new game yes well so it's almost like
building another game situation we are
in
yeah within the strummin that's exactly
there there there are bubbles of reality
which you know we can call culture yeah
and it comes down to one thing you for
the people out there you can either
you may either agree or disagree with
the statement that anything is possible
I I still have confidence issues with
that but it comes down to putting that
to the test because if you can
materialize anything in your mind that'd
be the most beautiful
think you would know what you're capable
of and then you would just do that every
day so it just comes down to like self
experimentation just try try something
small that's right I start going to the
gym you didn't think you could lift this
now you can lift that you didn't think I
mean in a PhD you know it in a way like
we're trying to introduce knowledge to
what we think or like I I thought that
we knew everything already until I
started doing research and for me to
come in and be like I have to lay the
foundations of knowledge it's weird it
feels like I'm bending the laws of
nature it's like it's hard to know where
to go or where to look
so so like sometimes it's just you know
whatever you want to see take yourself
there take that risks and if it doesn't
take you anywhere then you'll have your
answer but more times than not you'll
realize that it opens and it doesn't end
like you might explore something
impossible and start to see that it's
actually leading you to something you
might be afraid that it leads you astray
but even then what's the point of life
if you're not even enjoying being astray
because that's probably what our whole
lives might feel like it's about it's
like enjoying that chase to obviously
you know we need to be stable and make
money and things of that form but yeah
it's about challenging ourselves for
sure even that just that ending part
that we need to be stable we need to be
you know that's really what causes
people to stay in the hierarchy they
stay in the culture yes a simulation of
the bubble because it's safer it's safer
to be in the game that you know and it's
way harder to leave the game right new
code yeah and and obsolete the old code
either augment it in the original bubble
or build your new bubble yeah and bring
people to it I think thinking about it
that way is so damn important and it's
in many ways what what I'm trying to
piece together yeah right now with this
ultimate synthesis and it's the hardest
thing I've ever done
but at the same time I know that it's
gonna be the most rewarding one of the
things that I'm learning about it and
you know I'm interested to hear your
perspective on it is that I make more
progress towards the ultimate synthesis
when I disconnect from my cell phone
when I disconnect from the internet from
my laptop when I disconnect from those
things and I just sit like if I have a
spare 15 minutes in between interviews
at 30 like I'm not gonna I won't do
emails or texts or calls or definitely
not social media definitely not social
media and all and I'll just and I'll
just sit here and when I do that it's
very fascinating what silence can do for
what's going on within in mind at
developing further developing out the
creative thinking processes so what do
you think what what role do you think
disconnecting from the existing culture
plays in the development of the new maps
so the way I view it is that there's you
can be you can be like a recluse and
just not be in society but you need
context so it's it's not about what you
consume but it's your relationship with
what you're consuming and sometimes
let's say I'm on social media and I
might you know look at someone's little
life that might be that it might appear
better than mine I could sit there and
constantly attack myself by feeling that
way or use that to propel me and inspire
me towards something I would like to be
and if I believed that I could do
anything then all that person is doing
is bringing to my awareness the things I
want in my life it only hurts when I
feel like it's out of my reach and
that's fundamentally why anything causes
a suffering is that I want that and
cannot have it you know so it's it's
really about framing feeling the
confidence and power that you can do
those things and not placing those
limits
make the impossible public yes but if
you're in a position where the
consumption is not benefitting you it's
not serving you it's not making you feel
good you just have to notice that and
just not know that you not want to do
that but sometimes you're just caught in
the loop you don't know any better you
feel like it's what needs to happen but
again these are habits that you might
not know but you know if you tire
yourself out and feel enough pain and
stress you will live it literally like
exhaust yourself to the point where you
you'll have to take a nap and not look
at your phone so like really it's like
we're in a river flowing downstream but
really we're swimming upstream and we
think we're going upstream and once your
arms get tired it just carries you so
it's like you just with the stillness
and be you know being quiet there's a
part of you that already knows where you
need to go but you're just kind of your
mind is chattering so it's it's it's in
a weird way there's there's a part of
you that knows you better than you do
right now and it comes down to what does
it mean to listen to yourself I don't
know if I can you know if we don't have
the the hardcore technologies to do that
now but all we have is like our that
whatever that is I know meditation is
attempting to do that but we have all we
have different ways of entering
meditative States you know like for
example like sometimes I don't like
doing the dishes but sometimes I do it
takes attention away from my mind I'm
just feeling the plate feeling the water
whatever it takes for you to immerse and
what you're doing and just stop like
beating yourself up yeah is what it
takes yeah getting the ultimate flow
yeah I'm I have so many other questions
but we'll have to do another round
preferably there's a recording studio in
SF because there's still so much to
unpack about making new code to obsolete
the old code yeah I'm talking about the
old code I really like that out of box
thinking perspective and also I like how
you apply that to brain technology and
neural engineering and discipline and
cryptocurrency and biotech
in AI and robotics and spirituality and
unplugs applies to every single
economics every field needs the out of
box thinkers that have a fresh
perspective on asking the questions of
why is a banana yellow and why can't I I
want a purple banana how wide it purple
banana why can't I ride on the dragon
over the sunset well actually you can
it's just gonna take us a couple more
seconds yeah and you'll be able to and
yet to wrap that up and you know we
should stay in touch in regards to that
it comes down to simply being radically
honest what do I want I'll worry about
how we'll get it later it's just being
honest with what do I want because most
of the time it's what can I get you know
so that just it leaves you limited to
what your eyes can see but we can make
things so and I think if people could
start to shift in that way and we can
get together and just talk about what do
we want really make that the parameter
don't worry about the call I mean we
should costs and things like that come
later but it's like I would like let's
say imagine to have the simplest cure to
cancer you know like maybe that maybe
it's out there like you know it's just
to give us the opportunity to explore
explore things that might not seem
feasible right now because in a way we
stand on the shoulders of giants but we
need to ask the what the foundations are
and whether we could you know rise from
the ashes burn it down and do something
else
and when is that when when will that
happen doesn't need to happen
you know it's caused a discussion yeah
yeah yeah I'm so excited to talk about
new codes yeah we're we're in a
simulation and we are the programmers
ever simulation literally that question
on the way out so you the question is
are we in a simulation so I I personally
don't like using that word because
that's why and what you'd prefer yeah so
I think that when people say we're in a
simulation they think it's that there's
like legitimate numbers and code that
are like we're just like in a game that
we can mathematically
fine I think it's just it's it's way
beyond what we can describe right now in
a way if we want to take in neuroscience
perspectives our mind is generating the
reality in front of us what is beyond
our mind and eyes is another thing you
know either they're the objects are
actually there or we are collectively
generating as we go there is there may
be no object it's just simply us making
what we see in front of our eyes like
it's hard to tell where we're the power
during and hallucination yeah
and technically that's what it is it
comes down to how do we program it can
we program it if so what are we going to
program if I told you you could do that
it's like what I can what the way we're
game again what do I want yeah how do I
want to help others
we don't eat but even then we don't even
allow ourselves to think about that too
so important so it's a combination of
whether we're in a simulation or not
like even if we aren't if we have all
the power
we don't even ask those questions if we
aren't and this is all we have we could
still do something about it you know
what's the source code I think we are an
extension of something like I know I
don't think there's more beyond that I
mean let's ask you about this it is on
the 3d reality do we come into these
earth suits into the playground so
there's two ways to go about this either
we can all come up with the story and
that would be the real answer so I times
I I can't tell whether that there is
something making this happening or it's
up to us to come up with the story that
we can then prove in a weird way like it
in a way where we're very biased if
everything is connected we can show the
connections to whatever narrative we
want so that that but then it comes out
to I don't really care what's causing
this I'm here now I want to have a good
time at least I want you think about it
but yeah I you know it's we view 3d
technically there should be other
dimensions are they controlling us are
we puppets is
feedback are there no dimensions it's
simply just like is where an extension
of something altogether I personally
have never I don't know where I was
before I was born or where I've never
died I've only seen outside of my eyes
so I don't know you know so it's just
yeah it's I I think I think the beauty
is the mystery and when when there is
the mystery we can we can we can create
what we want in front of us at least
right now we're the surety of reality we
can build it we're chipping away more
and more yeah yeah so the it's I think
it's important to keep this in the back
of our mind because sometimes I reached
a point where I hit this existential
wall and I just needed to come up with
the story to keep myself going because
there there is no answer just yet but
yeah maybe yeah maybe in the Lange
language in realm of science we could
describe these things that's right
and I feel like sometimes if we develop
let's say brain technologies to augment
our brain to see different spectrums of
light to see different forms of energy
then our perspective is different so we
might need to augment our brain to see
more dimensions to make to even to
measure them so we're not we're not in a
position to even address or study or ask
those questions so it's like it's a
process so yeah but it's it's it's nice
to think about it you know I think we
are in a position to ask the questions
it's more about the details aren't there
yeah not yet and we have to build the
capacity to be able to poke at the
source code and gain a better
understanding of the source code of the
brain sort of civilization of what is
greater than us why we came here all the
types of questions last question is
what's the most beautiful thing in the
world awesome question
I think Beauty to me is novelty so it's
like it comes from an emergence of
something I've never experienced before
ah you know I think it comes from nature
and I think the feeling fundamentally
comes from relatedness and connectedness
with whatever I'm experiencing sometimes
it feel like feels like I'm injecting
the meeting in the beauty and sometimes
it's really just a little surprise
you know sometimes and III think I kind
of equate Beauty synonymously with like
on Wonder but also this feeling of
connectedness with anything like I I
could find beauty in the pebble
sometimes if you look at it long enough
so it's just this idea that we're here
and there are things there around us
that are miraculous yeah see I and III
think that question is inherently the
whole point of beauty is that it's it's
what's to come I would I find beautiful
is riding that dragging over the sunset
you know it's like it's an experience
I'm a candidate I might not even imagine
I might not even know it until I see it
so it's it's it's a chase so that's so
that's something that's the beauty of it
this has been very very fun and we have
done so many interviews where we talk to
different leaders at the edge about the
new codes that can maximize flourishing
and I'm really happy that we spent a
good chunk of time talking about that
it's a really outside the box thinking
about yeah about it and I love that yeah
thank you so much awesome yeah show it
and yes yeah anyone wants to build a
city I don't know how but you needs
people let's get together let's make
things happen thanks everyone for tuning
in and we love you very much thank you
so much also go and check out the link
below go to Lexi's work and reach out
help build this new code let's deploy
these new codes into the existing
infrastructure or obsolete it make some
new infrastructure and everyone support
the artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in our links are below for
simulation help us out also saw helped
out the organizations that you believe
in around the world and share more
conversations like this with other
people your families your friends your
co-workers online and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in we love you very much and
we'll see you soon bye guys
Daniel that was that was [ __ ] that
went better than I that I thought it
would and that's the stuff I wanted to
touch too